- I would like to
procure from the audience
five random topics or phrases,
and then,
I'll do a freestyle rap about them.
If you are in the section
I'm looking at right now..
what would you like a rap about?
(audience laughing)
Oh no, this is a conversation.
This isn't.. this isn't..
Heck wait,
did.. did someone heckle a forum
and got really told off?
Or you were like, no,
I've given you permission.
(audience laughing)
And I..I.. I'm like,
You're.. You're your dad?
Wait, are you making excuses for someone?
Oh, that's okay.
You're a dad. You are a dad.
What's your name? Dad.
- A..are Matt, are you simple?
(audience laughing)
Simple as that. Get yeah, no, dads..
dads will own up to
that. They'd be like no,
no I don't get things alright.
It was just..it was just yeah.
Matt, the dad. Okay.
Matt, what's your job?
Software? For which company?
Yeah, don't buy any software
from Matt's company.
(audience laughing)
Um, Matt who, Matt the dad
who has his own software company.
That's the first suggestion, mate.
You're gonna be in the rap.
That's pretty exciting.
- [Matt] Awesome!
Yeah. Matt excited. This side,
you've now had plenty of thinking time.
(audience laughing)
And if any of you say Carol, the mom,
then I will be very angry.
What would you like a rap about?
You're not in that side, but that is a
that is a good suggestion.
That's a real blast from the past.
For those of you that
don't know Tony Blair
was the Prime Minister
of the United Kingdom
elected in 1997. No
younger than that, mate.
Maybe it was before
that. Maybe not. Anyway,
he's a center left labor party.
Yeah. We'll rap about him. Um,
but you guys still have to come up
with something you're not off the hook
just because we've got Matt,
the software dad and Tony Blair.
Yes. A hand up here.
A Ferris wheel falling off
and rolling away. Thank you.
You engineering psychopath.
(audience laughing, clapping)
I got a ticket to Coney island.
Gonna have some fun.
Matt the software dad, Tony Blair,
Ferris will falling off and running away.
Let's come to the kind of the mass
in the middle front of the room.
What would you lovely
people like a rap about?
(audience laughing)
Okay. Um..
I mean, n.. number one,
you're not in the bit
I pointed at. Number two,
I did kind of say don't do foods. Um,
however, falafel is a good suggestion
'cause it has a special place in my heart.
One of my favorite place I've ever been
is a, um, a falafel restaurant
in the Marais, which is
the gay Jewish district
in Paris.. gay/ Jewish district
its not,
(audience laughing)
a very niche district in Paris.
(audience laughing hysterically)
Really specific ghetto. Isn't it? Um,
And there's a restaurant
called Le Falafel.
And I love that because
that is a palindrome.
Le Falafel reads the same forwards
as it does backwards. Isn't that clever
man over there who got it? Yeah.
And a falafel is also like a
visual palindrome, right?
'Cause it looks the
same going in as it does coming out.
(audience laughing)
Okay. Falafel.
Falafel, Matt the software dad,
Ferris wheel falling off and rolling away.
Tony Blair in front of the room.
He's he stole your suggestion.
So this is your chance for the final one.
What would you like a rap about?
Melania Trump. Well,
let's be, I mean, yeah.
She's.. she's been out of the the
public eye for a while, but then I guess
recently she did that whole kind of
uh huh, huhhhhh.
(audience laughing)
Which is always fun.
Um, What.. what about Melania
are you interested in?
And be respectful now, she is a lady.
(audience laughing)
Her thoughts?
Okay.
(audience laughing hysterically)
No.
Okay. This, this is a,
is going to be a freestyle.
It's a rap made up on the spot.
To do that we need some music.
So if my lovely, uh, DJ could drop a beat.
And uh, we're gonna have some fun.
W.. We, ohh smooth. So yeah,
it's going to be smooth and lovely.
And um, and what was our
other one that we had?
- Melania's thoughts.
Okay. Well I though I said that.
♪That's fine. We get it later.♪
♪Maybe we can court. Look at that♪
♪Melania Slovenia was in her thoughts?♪
♪Check her brain out. Usually she's like♪
♪this guy is so weird.♪
♪I know the president
forty-five admittedly.♪
♪The accent is up for discussion.♪
♪Blushing with embarrassment 'cause that♪
♪sounded Russian. But
maybe she's an agent♪
♪deep, undercover. Maybe in five years,♪
FBI will discover she was, planted there.♪
♪Yeah. They really need to ♪
♪weasel their way into the White House♪
♪as a sleeper.♪
♪Agent is what its called♪
♪Did she really take the reins?♪
♪Barron Trump, every time♪
♪you see him looks insane.♪
♪Like his whole passions drained.♪
♪That's Melanias son.♪
♪What are her thoughts about this?♪
♪What will he become?♪
♪He's grown up to like, six foot five.♪
♪Maybe the best Trump baller alive.♪
♪Go in there on the court,
maybe she would say♪
♪tuck him in at night. Yes.♪
♪The NBA is yours for the taking.♪
♪You could shoot those threes♪
♪and everyone will be like,♪
♪Well barren. Geez. You're amazing.♪
♪We were so mean at your dad.♪
♪Apologies for all the
online hate you had.♪
♪Melanias plan, it just
comes to fruition.♪
♪Meanwhile, Trump here
he's in the position.♪
♪Deep in the ground. Probably dead.♪
♪How, how does he feel?♪
♪He was ridin' an old
rickity Ferris wheel.♪
♪Right on the top.♪
(audience laughing)
♪He got to the circle
and then it went snapped♪
♪to the ground it hurt and he was like,♪
♪ah, it broke his body.
He was hurt y'all.♪
♪And then it rolled on
squirting, squirt more♪
♪all of the blood because ♪
♪it sprays like a Catherine wheel.♪
♪All the little things splashing off.♪
♪Trying to feel, some empathy♪
♪As it rolls to the ocean♪
♪usually is downhill at sea level motion.♪
♪Don't build a little
Ferris wheel on a mountain♪
♪Otherwise it drips down. Yeah,♪
♪I'm countin'♪
♪how many pieces of software I've had♪
♪that was so bad that clearly♪
♪made by Matt the dad♪
♪Then on the laptop♪
♪Then it just froze, everything stopped.♪
♪And so I just go to my email client.♪
♪Maybe Outlook or Gmail,♪
♪Send a little message to the dad,♪
♪not a female and say, yeah it failed.♪
♪I need my license back.♪
♪And Matts like, don't worry,♪
♪Chris I'll have a crack.♪
♪I'll come 'round, fixing it no trouble.♪
♪He does the dad thing♪
♪where he stretches out his knuckles♪
♪And settles down there at the keyboard.♪
♪I'm like, Matt, that's the fridge.♪
♪Are you sure?♪
♪You sat at the right computer.♪
♪He's like, I apologize.♪
♪Let me sit down here and
try this on for size.♪
♪I'm like, again Matt,
that's not the laptop.♪
♪That's just some taps♪
♪ and you turn it so they stop♪
♪dropping all the water,
he's so confused.♪
♪But still, you got a nice
little rap about you.♪
♪Isn't it fun Matt?♪
♪Don't you like it when the raps for what♪
♪you're going to treat yourself after♪
♪falafel.♪
♪Go down to Mac Moods ♪
♪or the Olive Tree. Try and get♪
falafel in Lebanon,♪
all you can eat. Maybe out to Bayou♪
♪bringing those things♪
♪taken in my mouth and I'm munching.♪
♪Impinging on the
hospitality with Tahini.♪
♪I put it on there.♪
I need some Sesame and see me♪
♪gettin' all my chickpeas♪
♪mush them in my castle♪
and more and then a deep fry.♪
♪Don't add water or a fire might happen.♪
♪It floats, doesn't mix.♪
♪If you want a sandwich
well don't put your♪
♪little dick in there. Why?♪
♪Because you'll collect some bacteria♪
♪and get the yeast infection.♪
♪"Fun".♪
♪Yeah I said I wouldn't rap that.♪
♪And they're doing like a two comment♪
♪before call back.♪
♪And now the last thing.♪
♪Is he up there? Well,
not in the morality area♪
♪Tony Blair. Why?♪
♪You went along with George Bush♪
♪and Colin Powell invaded Iraq,♪
♪yet we needed UK to allow.♪
♪They were backing up♪
♪their like♪
♪this suggestion that Saddam Hussein has♪
♪the nuclear weapons. They fell in♪
such a group of bad lads♪
♪That go and over there
for the fall of Baghdad.♪
♪But Tony Blair, well,♪
♪it's so many little policies that worked♪
♪an his wife called Sherry,♪
♪had a shortcut, bob.♪
♪It was black to the shoulders.♪
♪If you're not aware of this♪
♪I'm so glad that I told ya♪
♪I could have finished♪
♪with the thing about Matt but no.♪
♪About the PM in number, one, O♪
♪Number 10. That's the place♪
♪where they live in my country.♪
♪Got a nice black door, Tony Blair♪
♪he might hunt me down♪
♪and say, Chris, that rap was great.♪
♪And I'm like, fuck you why?♪
♪Because me and Matt are mates.♪
♪We'd be hanging out there,♪
♪bumpin' to the sound♪
(audience whoops)
♪I'm like me and Matt, ♪
♪we can go up to the fairground.♪
♪He's like, ah yeah,
Chris, how do you feel?♪
♪Did you know, I actually♪
♪designed this Ferris wheel.♪
(audience laughing)
♪I'm like, fuck Matt. No, not today.♪
♪I know it's so surely constructed.♪
♪It will roll away.♪
♪And so I leave him there♪
♪feeling kind of foolish♪
♪But he doesn't die so Matt♪
♪you fucking rule this.♪ Yeahhhh! ♪
(Loud horn 3x)